if at least he could get the king to  here and somehow give up the queen  or the rook and maybe even  if it's not made somewhere but maybe  yeah you know that if you defend very  well group against the queen with  knockouts  yeah so magnus is in semifinals  you know he was repeating moves here and  he forced himself to  play on yeah before himself but i guess  he was never  and here as well he was never  he not behind it you know he was playing  because he has to he didn't play because  he felt he's  yeah you know so yeah that's  and then just one more later like here  they're just repeating wolves  but it's fine it's fine losing it also  press day for  mondays to rest days  i think they're very good for them for  the people who are getting getting rest  because this must have been long term  yeah